i bet he can't wait to talk to me after
all these years
i have very fond memories of you
um having quite a bit to drink before
you would come out
on the show to calm your nerves and then
you'd be
fent
[Laughter]
please tell me you're in london please
tell me you're someplace where
no i'm in new york city home of the
brave i am in new york
uh it's beautiful it's blustery it's
cold
it's um yeah but it's also let me see
here
okay it's a little after three o'clock
in the afternoon
sure you're fine yeah i thought you were
were you about to be judgmental yes very
true
it's fun i don't give a [ __ ] when we're
going to do the interview now and i'm
going to really sort of
take on kind of a nasty persona and go
after you
afterwards i just wanted to get on first
and have a nice chat with you and then
totally switch
paul bettany if that's your real name
all right
let's start there it says here
uh all right let's do it yeah let's do
it or should i say
hair better me nice
it says here you flat your family fled
to argentina
1946 is that right here bethany
yeah you're a little blunt
you were part of a um
all right here we go i guess no more
laughing and having fun let's do the
interview for television here we go
my guest tonight is an extremely
talented actor who's appeared in
numerous films including avengers
infinity war
captain america civil war and avengers
age of
ultron and addition to many many other
great films
now he stars in one division on disney
plus
it is the show of the hour everyone's
talking about it uh please welcome the
extraordinarily talented paul
bettany paul how are you i'm tickly boo
how are you i don't know what that means
that sounds like a character in winnie
the pooh
it is it is i like uh
you know i have to take a second here to
talk about your incredible
wife uh jennifer connolly i know that
um i'm gonna tell you uh something i've
not revealed
uh which is that your wife jennifer was
on my show way back in 1993
and um i my heart exploded
i was i just instantly so smitten with
her
um and she's a
massive i had a massive crush
on jennifer connolly uh which remains to
this day
uh and i've been told to keep my
distance uh we've worked it out with
your security people
um i think i've been appropriate uh but
um i know that you
also uh had a crush on on your wife
long before you met her is that right
yes i just want to say you're not alone
uh and you know there is a support group
i want to go to this support group
please and we can be in this
together yes it's true i did i did have
a
crush on her i don't think i'm alone in
having a crush on her
but i just want to clarify that because
i
you know i'm hurtling towards my dotage
i'm 49 years old
and uh when i had a crush on her which
we i
you know i was like 14. all right
because because she was
she was 14 15 in when she was in
labyrinth so it always sounds a bit
weird saying
i fell in love with her the first time i
saw her in lebanon
yes you sound like a you can sound like
a creep unless you specify
that you were 14 uh
and uh it was a crush from afar which is
always appropriate
yeah totally i sat outside our house i
saw her comings and goings
you know i that's where i met you
i i met you because i was in some bushes
trying to get just a glimpse of this
beautiful and talented jennifer connolly
and suddenly someone was taking my usual
spot in the bushes and i'm like we had a
wonderful chat that day
[Laughter]
yes it's true i i did have a crush on
jennifer
which um is a little bit pathetic but
you know
no guess what it worked out i mean i
i i tip my imaginary cap to you
um it does occur to me that you have
this absolutely fantastic
british accent and occasionally and i
know you've you have
lived in the united states now for
20 years is that right 20 years and
i have spoken to many actors who've
uh transitioned to the united states and
they start to lose their accent you have
not
do you feel that you have assimilated
to being an american i do think that i
have learnt
i've learned a lot of things as an
american i've learned how to
uh fill a glass of wine all the way to
the top
that kind of thing
that is that is what we do we think
nothing of going right up to the rim
right to the brim because uncle hank
my american uncle hank tells me he says
um
filling it halfway causes a wasted
journey so
uh that was very very smart but i will
tell you the one thing
that i haven't been able to uh
figure out is how to wear a baseball cap
i just
it just doesn't work on me the whole the
whole game's
up if i try to wear one i kind of look
like um
well i kind of look like ron howard's
elderly brother
or something i have one here
oh there you go oh yes definite
you you look like ron howard's brother
who's an accountant yes
that's right it's just it's just it's
just not a lot that is
ever gonna work on me so yeah and and
that is something that seems to be
kind of mandatory in the united states
is that they insist that you wear a
baseball cap or everyone has to wear a
baseball cap
i don't wear a baseball cap because you
have i'm going to
compliment you now you have a very
chiseled lean face
um i have the large bloated pumpkin
the irish are cursed with and when i put
a baseball cap on it only makes my face
look
fatter it accentuates the fatness of my
face
and then i my self-loathing kicks in so
i i don't like it
um i i think that you and i should just
like knuckle down and start wearing
baseball caps you know what i
i took it off because i was ashamed of
uh
that's a shame but i'm gonna wear it
okay well i
i i think it looks terrible okay
well no because i'm massively shallow so
you said that
and my my vanity kicked in
so i you know yeah well i think you
you're obviously well dressed i like
your jacket is that a motorcycle jacket
well is it a motorcycle jacket i mean
it's like a motorcycle jacket if
dior did a motorcycle jack
i was wearing a motorcycle jacket and i
went it
it was in a bar in brooklyn i went into
a bar
and i sat down to have a drink and this
guy was like he was very drunk and he
looked at me with a nice
nice motorcycle jacket i went oh thank
you so much and he said
you have a motorcycle and i went uh
no he went to why you got a motorcycle
jack like this and i went
you're wearing a baseball hat do you do
you play
baseball you bastard
and that does that story end with you
being beaten very badly
yes it ends it ends with yes it ends
with me being beaten in the kidney
welcome to america yeah um
i uh i want to ask you this because my
children are very well versed in
everything marvel they know the whole
universe so
one division has been uh
they love it and what's a little
frustrating for me is i don't know the
marvel world as well as they do
so they have stopped me every 10 minutes
they want to stop and talk about
some clue that they just saw that has
great meaning
um and they they absolutely love it they
explained to me and i didn't know this
that your character your your
involvement with marvel
as vision started with you being the
voice of jarvis
and i knew that jarvis was the voice of
tony stark's computer and the iron man
films and i thought
they explained to me the whole evolution
of how
jarvis becomes vision and i thought
thank you children
i appreciate that what i didn't know was
how
you got that part in the first place how
did you get the part
of jarvis uh yeah it was i made a
movie years ago called wimbledon and in
wimbledon john
favreau played my agent rather
brilliantly
and then john favreau then sort of
became a big
director and he he called me up and he
said paul
paul and i said yes john how are you and
he said i'm really well i want what can
i do for you and he said
well i'm making this movie
and there's that it's iron man so
they're you know there's tony stark
and he has this suit and i need this
disembodied voice
of a sort of a a
you know a personality less
you know computer voice somebody with
just like no
character at all and i thought of you
immediately
[Laughter]
well john since you've pitched it so
nicely
um yeah i'm in and and that was how it
all began
well it's uh first of all i i you know
i i do disagree with him i think you've
got loads of personality
uh but um it worked out because you you
were jarvis
then uh jarvis becomes the vision
role and i'm thinking and now vision is
this very central part of this huge
franchise
and has led to one division so it's
beautiful
beautiful the way it all laid out for
you but what i'm here
what i'm curious about is marvel they
put so much thought
so much thought into everything and i
know that when they're creating a new
character
we're adapting a character from the
comics to film
they put an immense amount of thought
into what the character should look like
and there's this legend that they go
through hundreds of different
prototypes and looks before they settle
on one did that happen with vision
yes yeah there was there was a lot of
work
done on that and just whedon was
um was uh manning the ship
at that point and he was you know
because
right at the beginning he was wondering
like vision's going to be born
we're going to see him uh born and and
as i mean extensively naked
he has to have a penis
right i mean because he's he's naked and
he's been born
and everybody there loves this positive
kevin feig everybody was like
i'm not sure that's such a great idea
for vision to have you know for us
for him to sort of rise up out of the
crypt as it were with a with a you know
a penis and he said i need i
i need i need him to i need to see his
penis
so and this is a true story so there was
so artists were sent away to sort of
do all of these renderings of vision
being born
with with a with the penis and
they they they put them all up on this
huge wall of marvel studios
and they invited um they invited just in
and just stood
in front of this huge wall and he went
never have i been more sure that i don't
need to see
visioning with a penis
yeah because you don't want to see that
yeah yeah
when we were launching my show back in
93 there was a lot of discussion should
conan have a penis or not
and what did you decide we without uh oh
you went with that yeah it just um and
it
that seems to be better yeah who needs
it you know
um i'm who ever got me into the trial
it's just exactly
uh i'll make sure i get the word out
that the finale of one division streams
on disney plus
tomorrow and uh everyone's watching it
it is
it's just been it must be fun for you
that it
you couldn't have imagined that it would
hit like this
absolutely not we we were not supposed
you know we were supposed to come out
second
and we were all we always kind of
thought we were going to be the kooky
cousin
kind of you know and cp embrace like
this has just been amazing
to disseminate it um
week after week has also been great and
um
i've got a lot of mixed emotions about
that finishing
today like it's yeah it's gonna be out
and
we've crashed the disney um the disney
plus platform
twice that's fantastic yes that's
fantastic whenever you can break
anything that disney has made
i can't believe it like so many people
wanted to watch it and i was like
wow it was uh yeah so tonight everybody
tune in and
tune in and let's yes let's destroy uh
let's destroy a streaming service
tonight let's do it together
let's do it hey paul uh my best to you
and to your lovely wife uh tell her i'll
you know
it was been a long time but um yeah
she you know what keep holding that
torch i think she's bored of me
you know it's been it's been it's been
12 months together clearly she has a
thing for men with no skin tone
at all no pigment so
i could just you know step in one day
and even notice
it'll be oh look it's another guy who
looks like he has some kind of bone
marrow illness
uh paul bettany thank you so much really
appreciate this was fun
yeah that's so nice talking to you yeah
good and congratulations
very happy for you mwah okay all right
cheers
you